simon plantes et gestionnaire de
portefeuille à la financière banque
nationale bonsoir comment vous expliquer
l'ampleur du mouvement à la baisse
aujourd'hui au mois de janvier à
regarder le marché puis avait une
certitude parce que ces dix la demande
de comprendre l'impact économique
l'impact financier d'une contagion au
mois de janvier on a peur que mais
depuis on est aussi on a observé les
résultats trimestriels de la saison des
résultats et les résultats aux états
unis en particulier ont été vraiment
bien donc on a eu un mois même temps
puis soudainement même l'immédiat
mentionnait mais on semble oublier c'est
ce facteur de risque là est ce qu ont
été rendus à le sous-estimer mais
probablement parce qu'aujourd'hui on
voit que la contagion bien à toucher du
vers python tout vous parlez l'italie
l'ira la corée du sud
puisqu'on voit pas ce qui est une bonne
nouvelle c'est que dans ces pays le clip
et aux périphériques ajuste promptement
salle un impact économique laquelle pour
combien de temps c'est ce qui est
difficile à chiffrer puis pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on voit un recul
ouais on va montrer le graphique la
cassure a été net aujourd'hui plus de
1000 points par rapport à vendredi pour
les principaux indices c'est vraiment
arrivé aujourd'hui en fin de semaine
contenu qui a eu une forte montée des
cas en italie qui ont été rapportés est
ce que cette chute va se poursuivre je
vous demande pas de nounou prévoir
d'avancé et ce qu'on ressent une forme
de panique ou de fortes inquiétudes qui
est rentré dans le marché première fois
pour être usé le sens on regarde le
graphique depuis le 1er janvier dans son
oeuvre que mot revient au niveau de
janvier où on était à la genèse de la
contagion donc l'évaluation du marché on
voit vraiment que c'est d'évaluer cet
impact là parce que ça pue ça peut
continuer va effectivement oui si la
contagion se propage par contre les
dédales encourageante son regard d'un
chien première machine la province du
yunnan faut se rappeler l'eau le slip
centre le provinciaux en correspond à
peu près à 5% du pib de la chine
puis on voit que dans cette province
l'axé mais il ya plus de gens qui
quittent les hôpitaux
quels gens qui rentrent donc on voit
qu'en chine certain ralentissement
est ce qu'on peut voir la même tangente
dans certains pays
europe c'est l'avenir nous le dira oui
quels sont les secteurs qui sont les
plus touchés par ce qui se passe
maintenant
ben évidemment les producteurs de
matières premières parce que l'enjeu
qu'on parle ce qu'ils vont ralentir
économique tout ce qui est plus sensible
aux cycles économiques vont être
affectés aux producteurs de matières
premières
on a vu tout à l'heure les transporteurs
aériens sont aux premières lignes
donc ce matin il y avait des principaux
sociedad aérienne qui mentionnait qu'un
refusait totalement sans savoir ça va
être quoi sa projection pour l'année
parce qu'on est dans l'incertitude
il n'y a pas très longtemps je vous ai
parlé puis je vous ai dit vous viendrez
nous parler quand on sera tranquilles
d'argent du jamais vu chez les 30 mai
point finalement il est tombé sous les
28 mai aujourd'hui dans le fond ya une
nervosité qui existe qui est toujours un
moment où on va assister à une forme de
décrochage après onze ans de croissance
boursière
oui et puis tu te rends tu me donnes
immense et donner l'exemple de voir une
belle fête qui ont investi en bourse on
achète des parts d'entreprises
l'autre entreprise ça doit être basé son
béret les stratégies des raisons
fondamentales
à travers ce vote toujours des
variations positives comme négatives
puis actuellement coronavirus fait
partie de la réalité dans les dix
prochaines années on va en vivre
d'autres situations comme ça mais je
lisais aujourd'hui des analyses qui
disait voilà c'est le déclencheur ces
déclencheurs pour une correction de 10
15 jusqu'à 20 pour ça mais si je pense
qu'on ne peut pas savoir c'est ça ça
peut être le déclencheur comme au mois
de février on a dit bon résultat qui
finalement n'est la bourse à la hausse
entre au début de l'année les sociétés
ont révisé leur projection puis la barre
relativement baisse
donc on prévoit prochains trimestres
d'autres bons résultats que d'autres
facteurs aussi moi qui m'amène à être
plus optimistes esquermes exemple en
2019 le marché progresser fortement
mais il ya eu une sortie de capitaux
dans les marchés boursiers et
aujourd'hui on regarde il ya environ aux
états unis 2000 milliards de dollars qui
sont sur les lignes de côté en
liquidités en obligations puis si je
suis investi en obligations
exemple au canada un obligations
canadiennes chance disons enfin
rendement a beau de 1,5 pour cent à bord
de 1.3 % pour 1 obligation de trente ans
après face aux roumains négatif donc des
baisses comme ça ça permet
certains investisseurs a justement
profité de cette baisse là pour intégrer
le marché
un autre point qui pourrait rassurer les
investisseurs' et si finalement cette
contagion l'épidémie se propage vont
prévoir des banques centrales finir à la
réserve fédérale revenir à la rescousse
avec des baisses de taux d'intérêt
pourrait aider le marché ce qui pourrait
alimenter le marché
oui et gonflé un peu la bulle du marché
je peux d'accord avec la nation bull
c'est vrai qu'il ya certains secteurs
d'activité exemple en technologie des
starts-up on regarde les aberrations
sont relativement élevés soit fait par
contre on regarde certains secteurs
d'activité puis ils font du surplace du
docu un bon certain temps donc son
regard des évaluations il ya encore des
opportunités tout à vous parler de ces
révélations même en teck les grandes
sociétés technologies sont regarde par
exemple des périodes bulle technologique
en 1998 99
on est loin d'avoir les mêmes multiples
bien merci beaucoup sur mon plan pour
analyse ce soir merci bien